listen I love Canada you know I've been
all up and through Vancouver
Saskatchewan Calgary
Ottawa Toronto okay Montreal Fierce I
was there for Pride yes indeed I've been
all I've been through I've been to Saint
John okay I've been all up and through
I love Canada you're a Canadian hey
pretty much
we love snow that's right look at us yes
I like the warm times in Canada
hallelujah hallelujah okay
the finale is coming up tonight there
was a bit of a scare
I was clutching my pearls you guys
shouldn't have been there that's just my
opinion but what are we thinking going
into finale
baby category closed okay they'd have
messed up and put the drag Dave off in
the finale all right now listen I am so
grateful because Glenn and I have worked
so hard to be in this moment but now
they give us a freestyle I have spent 10
weeks molding myself unsickling my feet
doing the bunch of photos and the kogo
chahawas whatever the word she knows
he's dead so I don't know go to photos
okay thank you that's all that I did all
that okay now I get a freestyle to be
able to bring to the ballroom everything
that I've learned in being a drag Diva
Entertainer across the world everything
that I've learned from my mother RuPaul
and all the drag divas that have
inspired me to this moment baby we're
gonna bring it to the ballroom okay so
they better watch out for the a finale
because it's on
I love it Lady Gaga was shouting you out
on Instagram it was so nice to see
wanting everyone to vote for you how are
you feeling about that grateful so it's
Lady Gaga one of the world's most
talented and kindest entertainers and
the fact that she would take time from
her very busy schedule because you know
the doll ain't sitting around just
watching TV okay she's got things to do
and the fact that she would show us love
on Instagram in that way I'm I bow down
to the Gaga and I appreciate it because
the little monsters I'm one of them we
show up
okay let's talk about Len saying goodbye
I'm very emotional what are your
thoughts both of you
well then is the heart of the ballroom
you know uh he's made a huge impact on
the show and he's a huge made a huge
impact on me even though I started the
show only from season 16 and he's been
there from season one you know he's an
amazing knowledgeable authentic Ballroom
judge you know all of the critiques that
he said all over the years to every
single couple including myself you know
we all took on board and we go went and
worked on that and that what made us and
our celebrities a better dancers you
know so we're gonna miss him so so much
but I guess it's live you know he's got
to do what he's got to do what are your
thoughts uh well Mr Lynn is the first
person to ever teach me about crispy
legs Okay so I will never see another
drumstick without thinking of The
Amazing Heart
that smile that laugh and that amazing
critique you know that the true critique
the professional critique that has
helped me to get to this moment awesome
thank you guys and good luck next week